[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportages et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat donner du sens à l'actualité c'est
notre objectif et c'est ce que l'on va
tenter de faire ce soir avec deux débats
le scandale de corruption au sommet du
Parlement européen pour commencer la
vice-présidente la socialiste grecque et
vacailli arrêter en flagrant délit le
Qatar accusé en pleine coupe du monde de
foot et c'est toute l'institution qui
est fragilisée quelle est l'ampleur du
phénomène que peut révéler l'enquête des
policiers belges comment renforcer la
transparence et le contrôle des députés
européens réponse dans une minute et
puis dans trois quarts d'heure je vous
emmène en Inde avec 1,4 milliards
d'habitants l'an prochain ce sera le
pays le plus peuplé au monde le Premier
ministre n'a rendra maudit veut en faire
la nouvelle usine de la planète
allez vendre n'importe où dans le monde
mais produisez et manufacturés ici
nous avons des capacités du talent de la
discipline et la détermination pour
faire beaucoup
nous voulons offrir des opportunités
favorables au monde entier alors venez
et fabriquer en Inde
cet appel date d'il y a 8 ans a-t-il
réussi son pari l'Inde peut-elle dans
quelques années supplanté la Chine ne
ratez pas l'analyse de nos experts tout
à l'heure mais d'abord donc gros plan
sur ce catargate ses valises de billets
c'est députés corrompus et son Parlement
européen sous le choc Pierre Henry
holderborn
après avoir tremblé le Parlement
européen passe aux sanctions vous
voterez sur une proposition de la
Conférence des Présidents le vote est
quasi unanime
sur 628 voies 625 sont favorables et
mettent fin au mandat de vie président
d'Eva Kylie et le vote est adopté dans
une prise de parole la présidente du
Parlement européen annonce une enquête
interne
nous allons lancer une enquête interne
pour examiner tous les faits liés au
Parlement
et voir comment nos systèmes peuvent
devenir encore plus étanche la députée
européenne grecque Eva Kylie a été
interpellé vendredi et elle est
soupçonnée d'avoir été payée pour
défendre les intérêts du Qatar comme le
montre ce discours douteux du 21
novembre dernier
j'ai été la seule à dire que le Qatar
est un leader en matière de droit du
travail
pourtant certains ici appellent à les
discriminer il les intimides et accuse
de corruption tous ceux qui leur parlent
ou s'engagent et pourtant il consomme
leur gaz leurs entreprises ils gagnent
des milliards
au total une vingtaine de personnes ont
été perquisitionnées en quatre jours
trois personnes dont son mari sont
écroués le parquet fédéral belge a saisi
plusieurs milliers d'euros 600.000 euros
au domicile d'un suspect plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros dans une
chambre d'hôtel et environ 150 000 euros
dans un appartement d'un député européen
à la télé grecque l'avocat de l'ex
vice-présidente affirme qu'elle n'a reçu
aucun argent de la part du Qatar sa
position c'est qu'elle est innocente
elle n'a rien à voir avec les peaux de
vin du Qatar un scandale qui a traversé
les frontières pour atteindre son pays
d'origine la Grèce l'autorité de lutte
contre le blanchiment d'argent à quant à
lui gelé tous les avoir déva Kylie et de
ses proches de son côté le cathare
d'aimant être impliqué dans des
tentatives de corruption
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de ce premier débat de sciences
publiques mais de niveau gel bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice écologiste
des Françaises et les Français de
l'étranger qu'au président du Parti vert
européen chlory d'elle bonsoir aux
fonctionnaires directrices adjointe de
l'Institut Rousseau triste de ce livre
d'une guerre à l'autre publie aux
éditions de l'Aube Sylvain Kane bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi enseignant
chercheur au Centre d'histoire de
Sciences Po et puis je signale votre
podcast l'Europe des présidents qui est
disponible sur Web audio vous revenez en
8 épisodes sur les relations entre les
chefs d'État français et la construction
européenne Mathieu croissant d'aubonsoir
Mathieu éditoris politique bienvenue à
vous aussi pour commencer je voudrais
savoir comment vous évaluez le l'ampleur
de ce scandale mais la niveau gel c'est
c'est fait reprocher à donc l'ex
vice-présidente du Parlement européen
sont évidemment gravissimes vous dites
quoi qu'à isolé peut-être le le premier
d'une série vous dites quoi alors ça
peut pas être un cas isolé c'est
impossible d'avoir dans une situation
comme ça un
en groupe il faut il faut quand même
avoir conscience que c'est là pour
l'instant on a découvert quelques
personnes il y a quelques personnes qui
sont en prison mais c'est l'ensemble du
groupe socialiste au Parlement européen
moins la délégation française qui a voté
contre par exemple mettre à l'ordre du
jour une résolution sur le Qatar c'est
impossible d'arriver à convaincre
l'ensemble du groupe socialiste si on
n'a pas un réseau qui s'est établi de
façon assez profonde pendant assez
longtemps donc moi je pense enfin moi
j'imagine le groupe des verres au
Parlement européen s'il y a un député
qui arrive un jour et qui essaye de
convaincre tous ses collègues écoutez en
fait on va pas voter pour dire que il y
a un problème avec les droits humains au
Qatar
la probabilité que ça marche on va lui
dire écoute tu es gentil il faut
peut-être que tu ailles faire un tour
mais ça va pas marcher pour que ça
marche il faut qu'il y ait eu une
influence assez profonde pendant assez
longtemps et donc moi je pense que
j'ai bien peur que ce soit que le sommet
émergé de l'iceberg et qu'on découvre
plus de choses et aussi on se rend
peut-être pas compte à quel point ça
c'était une résolution non contraignante
au Parlement européen et ils sont prêts
à mettre on l'a ce qu'on voit c'est un
million d'euros pour avoir une une prise
de parole plutôt favorable au cas tard
vous imaginez ce qu'ils sont capables de
mettre quand on a des vrais votes
contraignants sur des décisions qui vont
avoir une valeur juridique je pense
qu'on est juste au début de la faire
alors justement le Qatar est peut-être
d'autres pays on est on y viendra
évidemment Chloé Ridel est-ce que vous
êtes surprise quand vous quand vous
voyez cette affaire éclatée là il y a
on ne peut qu'être surpris parce que les
faits sont d'une telle gravité cher on
est face à une faillite politique et
morale mais malheureusement
effectivement je pense que ça que la
face immergée d'un iceberg qui est
l'iceberg de notre incapacité à faire
corps vis-à-vis du reste du monde nous
avons été depuis des décennies nous
Européens faibles face aux puissances
étrangères qui ne nous voulaient pas que
du bien mais aussi face aux puissances
de l'argent en étant incapable face à
ces puissances là de défendre notre mode
de vie au cœur de valeur nos principes
et il y a plein d'exemples de cela
aujourd'hui on voit une député près
effectivement à s’asseoir sur les droits
humains et à dire que les droits le
droit du travail à respecter au Qatar
pour 600.000 euros mais on a plein
d'autres exemples qu'on peut citer il y
a un rapport du Parlement européen sur
les ingérences étrangères qui a été
publié au mois de mars qui montrent que
300 millions d'euros ont été dépensés
ces dernières années par la Chine la
Russie l'Arabie Saoudite et les pays du
Golfe à des femmes d'ingérence dans nos
processus démocratiques on a à la faveur
de la guerre en Ukraine pris conscience
de l'ampleur aussi de la corruption
morale de nos élites avec des anciens
chefs de gouvernement qui allaient
travailler pour des entreprises chinoise
etc et puis il y a un autre exemple que
je veux citer dont on ne parle pas assez
qui est le phénomène des passeports
dorés en Europe
15 ans ça consiste à quoi les passeports
dorés ça consiste à vendre la
nationalité d'un pays européen ce qui
donne immédiatement accès à la
citoyenneté européenne à qui au combien
symbolique de la construction européenne
et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec ça
c'est que des pays comme la Grèce Malte
Chypre le Portugal ont vendu à partir de
début des années 2010 leur nationalité
leur passeport des visas ce qui donnait
contre de l'argent ce qui donnait accès
à la nation à la citoyenneté européenne
et donc au droit de circuler librement
dans l'espace européen d'investir de se
présenter aux élections et c'est à dire
que on vendait à des riches chinois
saoudiens et russes la citoyenneté
européenne et qu'on laissait mourir des
étrangers plus pauvres dans l'eau froide
de la Méditerranée donc c'est ce genre
de choses si vous voulez qu'il faut
totalement dont il faut totalement
tourner la page et depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine il y a quand même je
pense une prise de conscience
et on voit bien que il faut qu'on puisse
faire corps face au reste du monde pour
défendre nos principes et nos valeurs
plutôt que de les vendre plus offrants
Sylvain kan votre analyse sur l'ampleur
de ce de ce que ce scandale révèle
finalement bah écoutez je
ne serait-ce que pour le jeu le jeu du
débat je vais me déporter un peu par
rapport à ce qui a été dit non non pas
du tout en disant que c'est pas très
grave la question qui est posée c'est
l'ampleur sur l'ampleur
on peut avoir des intuitions on peut
dire
c'est la catastrophe etc pour l'instant
on n'en sait rien je veux dire c'est
très grave
on est au début de l'enquête c'est ce
que oui vous dites que c'est pas
possible que ce soit des cas isolés que
c'est forcément la partie immergée
immergée pardon d'un iceberg qui est
forcément immense vous dites que c'est
l'ensemble du groupe socialiste moi j'en
sais rien je suis pas parlementaire ce
que je sais en tant que socialiste a
voté contre bien sûr
disons je me ferais non pas l'avocat du
diable mais juste pour qu'on essaye
d'avoir un débat à 180 degrés d'abord
ce qui arrive là au Parlement européen
sauf
erreur de ma part j'ai lu le billet de
Jean Quatremer ce matin qui pense que
lui aussi c'est la révélation d'une
culture de l'impunité qui existe depuis
10-15 ans bon c'est pas faux mais ça me
paraît quand même un peu excessif donc
ce qui arrive aujourd'hui au Parlement
européen et quelque chose j'ai envie de
dire qui est malheureusement et vraiment
malheureusement mais assez
consubstantiel au Parlement
démocratique dans les régimes
parlementaires c'est à dire que
dans un régime parlementaire on en a
beaucoup de cas dans l'histoire y
compris très récente on l'a vu en Italie
dans les années 80 on l'a vu en France
dans les années 80 et 90 pour ne prendre
que deux pays qu'on connaît bien on le
voit en Belgique là en ce moment même en
Belgique le Parti socialiste belge
wallon et lui-même pourronter à deux cas
dans les dans les dans le groupe de
parlementaires socialiste européen il y
a deux euros députés belges wallons qui
sont complètement concernés donc ce que
je veux dire c'est que on peut aussi
considérer que lorsque un parlement d'un
régime parlementaire démocratique et
confronté à ce type de problème qui sont
très graves on sait on sait soit tout de
suite soit assez rapidement en général
il y a une action une réaction et donc
en un sens
le fait que ça réagisse aussi vite que
vous dites quoi pardon je vous
interrompre parce que la démonstration
est vraiment très long mais ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que heureusement qu'il
y a ce scandale parce que des millions
de contrôle
ce que je veux dire c'est que il faut
pas tout d'un coup dire vous l'avez bien
dit l'Europe c'est vraiment la
catastrophe surtout les plans il y a les
migrants il y a les passeports ceux-ci
il y a ceci quand même donc vous dites
quoi
étrangères et en fait le Parlement
européen c'était pas moins bien que les
autres euh
démocraties qui se sont dotés quand même
de règles éthiques ou ou déontologiques
un peu plus stricte et un peu plus ferme
à commencer la fourmi par exemple
un règlement de l'Assemblée un peu plus
précis puisqu'il existe au Parlement
européen moi ce qui me frappe mais ça ça
explique aussi que cette affaire là elle
révèle une nouvelle fois une forme de
naïveté et de laisser faire de la part
des institutions européenne on l'a eu
sur un plan économique face à la
mondialisation on l'a eu sur un plan
monétaire quand l'euro a été attaqué on
l'a eu sur un plan du terrorisme ou les
pays entre eux ne se mettaient pas
d'accord pour échanger leurs
informations on l'a désormais sur un
plan géopolitique avec cet incroyable
naïveté de découvrir que des puissances
étrangères tentent d'influer les
décisions européennes comme c'est un
choc en Italie un choc qui peut être
salutaire mais c'est un choc vraiment
énorme de ça c'est vrai pour l'ensemble
des des états il y a eu des scandales
dans les vous citer mais il y a eu des
mesures qui ont été prises il va y avoir
des mesures
sauf que si vous nous dites c'est
possible dans toutes les démocraties
pourquoi l'Europe a pas pris ces mesures
de contrôle plus strict vis-à-vis de ces
députés auparavant pourquoi faut-il
attendre un scandale pour le faire je
vous vois dans la parole et ensuite vous
là
il faut se poser la question en France
pourquoi a-t-il fallu attendre le
scandale qu'à usaac en 2013 pour qu'on
ait la route autorité la transparence
dans la vie publique bon c'est très
récent pourquoi a-t-il fallu attendre
2016 pour avoir la loi Sapin 2 vous
voyez donc je veux dire et pourtant la
France est une vieille démocratie
parlementaire beaucoup plus ancienne que
la démocratie européenne mais la nyogène
alors la régulation là il faut quand
même bien comprendre qu'on est dans un
cas de corruption on est sur du pénal on
n'est pas sur la régulation du lobbying
en général on en parlera mais bon la
régulation du lobbying au niveau
européen et sur beaucoup d'aspects plus
avancés que dans la moyenne des pays
européens oui mais là je parle du
contrôle de de la transparence vis-à-vis
des députés de leurs actions de leurs
biens avec tel ou tel sens économique
etc dans quelques pays européens et
aussi au Canada qui est globalement
quelque chose qui fait défaut de manière
générale
et nous on a toujours poussé je dis nous
les écologistes au Parlement européen je
crois que ce que c'était mon travail
avant je travaillais sur ces questions
là au groupe écologiste au Parlement
européen toutes les avancées qu'il y a
eu sur le registre de transparence des
lobbies sur le fait que les députés
européens soient obligés de de publier
les rendez-vous qu'ils avaient avec les
avec les lobbies etc ont été des
batailles qui ont été obtenus c'est pas
pour dire aligné en une meilleure que
les autres mais bon grâce aux
écologistes et toujours avec une
résistance très forte et maintenant
c'est vrai que je regarde certaines
négociations avec un regard un petit peu
voilà douteux avec une très forte
opposition de la droite mais aussi des
socialistes qui ont toujours considéré
qu'au fond en démocratie c'est le vote
qui voilà vous donne le droit ou essayer
des gens ne sont plus d'accord avec ce
que vous avez vous aideront pas la
prochaine fois et qui ont donc toujours
résisté contre contre ce contrôle mais
je voudrais pas qu'on dise que il y a
pas de contrôle au niveau européen il y
en a il est insuffisant il doit être
renforcé toutes les demandes qu'on a
fait depuis des années sur le fait par
exemple que les députés européens après
la fin de leur mandat et une période de
latence pendant laquelle il ne puisse
pas exercer exercer certaines fonctions
pour qu'il ne puissent pas revendre leur
influence par exemple c'est des choses
qui existent le pantouflage
habituellement ou
est-ce qu'on oui enfin non pas ouais
enfin bref
je sais pas comment ça en français
parce que là on voit qu'il y a un ancien
député européen qui a impliqué qui a pu
revendre son influence j'espère que
toutes ces toutes ces propositions là
qu'on fait depuis des années vous pouvez
enfin être appliqué et c'est vrai
malheureusement souvent c'est après des
scandales que les règles se se rendent
je vais vous redonner la parole mais je
voudrais quand même qu'on réécoute on en
a vu un extrait assez court dans le dans
le sujet d'ouverture on réécoute et va
Kylie donc à l'époque encore
vice-présidente du Parlement européen on
est le 21 novembre et et enfin c'est
juste pour illustrer le cynisme quand
même elle parle de corruption dans dans
cette prise de parole
ils se sont engagés dans une vision par
choix et ce sont ouverts au monde
pourtant ici certains appellent à les
discriminer il les intimides et accuse
de corruption tous ceux qui leur parlent
ou s'engagent et pourtant il consomme
leur gaz leurs entreprises y gagnent des
milliards
donc le ridle elle se sent visée elle
dit on accuse ce qui ose défendre le
Qatar de confiance j'ai une double
question sur ce cynisme mais peut-être
aussi ce qu'elle c'est quoi le pouvoir
d'une vice-présidente au Parlement
européen qu'est-ce que ça représente
quand on dit c'est le plus haut du de
l'Institut c'est un pouvoir d'influence
et puis c'est un symbole c'est quand
même la vice-présidente d'une des plus
grandes institutions européennes et puis
la plus démocratique alors il y a quatre
c'était là c'est pour ça que je posais
la question
c'est pas la seule effectivement mais je
pense que comment dire la corruption
déjà européenne quand on la regarde il
faut la regarder dans toute son ampleur
elle ne s'arrête pas au Parlement
européen il faut considérer on en parler
tout à l'heure le phénomène de
pantouflage d'anciens dirigeants et
d'ailleurs à l'extérieur de Bruxelles
comme l'ancien chancelier allemand
Gérard Schroeder qui va travailler pour
un grosse Prusse comme François Fillon
comme Jean-Pierre Raffin il faut aussi
considérer la corruption de certaines de
nos grandes entreprises quand on voit
par exemple les géants automobile en
Chine Volkswagen etc qui nous dit son
patron qui nous dit que le génocide des
ouigo il n'y croit pas parce qu'il ne
l'a pas vu de ses propres yeux donc en
fait si vous voulez le devoir
d'exemplarité qu'à l'Europe dans
vis-à-vis du reste du monde ne s'arrête
pas au Parlement européen c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus vaste qui nous
faut régler et ça ne sert à rien de
relativiser des problèmes comme celui-ci
quand il arrive c'est de dire oui mais
l'Europe n'est pas si mauvaise etc
évidemment quand on regarde les
classements internationaux un peu quand
on regarde les classements
internationaux de la corruption dans le
monde les pays européens sont les pays
les moins corrompus du monde c'est c'est
notre modèle c'est ce qui fait notre
spécificité et c'est justement la raison
pour laquelle nous avons un devoir
d'exemplarité ça nous grandit et donc il
faut évidemment se saisir de ce scandale
pour prendre des mesures j'entends des
propositions pour une commission
d'enquête qui je crois va être validée
une proposition aussi pour la création
d'une haute autorité de la transparence
de la vie publique européenne sur le
même modèle que la française qui je
crois plutôt bien depuis un certain
nombre d'années donc il faut se saisir
de cela pour progresser mettre en place
aussi des règles pour empêcher que des
chefs d'État européens n'ont pas des
gens qui travaillent forcément les
institutions européennes aussi naï
travaillait pour les intérêts de
puissance étrangères etc etc et c'est
une bonne occasion que ce scandale c'est
un peu bizarre de dire ça comme ça mais
pour aller plus loin et prendre
conscience de l'ampleur du problème
Sylvain kan est-ce que c'est aussi la
démocratie européenne qui est visée
finalement avec ces avec ses actions de
corruption disons allez viser on
pourrait dire de fait je il est peu
probable que le but des corrupteurs
catharris il s'agit bien de Qataris
puisque ça pour l'instant c'est des
suppositions qu'on fait puisque les les
juges chargés de l'enquête on parlait
d'un pays de la péninsule arabique le
lien entre les prunes bien sûr
c'est le début de l'année il est disons
j'en sais rien mais il est improbable me
semble-t-il que le but ça soit
d'attaquer la démocratie le but c'est de
défendre les intérêts du Qatar y compris
par la corruption et probablement par
beaucoup de moyens possibles la
démocratie quand même que les votes
soient conditionnées à des valises
depuis bien sûr non mais je réponds à la
question la question c'est est-ce que
c'est l'objectif non est-ce que c'est
une conséquence oui bien entendu mais là
aussi je veux dire
à ce moment-là si on dit que c'est une
conséquence voir un objectif il faut
regarder quelles sont les résultats donc
encore une fois c'est très important de
savoir si c'est
quelque chose de plutôt isolé ou de
représentatif d'une grande graine ou
d'un cancer qui métastaserait l'ensemble
du Parlement européen pour le savoir il
va falloir enquêter bien entendu mais
aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore sûr que
ça soit le cas deuxièmement sauf erreur
de ma part les effets de cette
corruption pour l'instant me semble-t-il
sont comment dire relativement
circonscrit il y a pas de parfois majeur
dont sur lequel les votes étaient
influencés dans la même semaine où ce
scandale encore une fois très grave je
ne le mésim pas je ne le relativise pas
je dis simplement qu'il faut pas jeter
le bébé avec l'eau du bain il y a eu la
même semaine deux votes extrêmement
important du Parlement européen dont la
veille encore toute la presse française
et européenne disait que c'était
formidable extraordinaire exemplaire
pour reprendre vos mots l'un sur la
lutte contre la déforestation l'autre
sur la taxe carbone aux frontières bon
voilà il y a un télescopage de
l'information donc en même temps on a
les deux vous voyez les faits calamiteux
de ce scandale parce que parce que ces
deux décisions elles sont en train de
passer un peu un peu sous les radars
médiatiques non mais ça c'est pas grave
médiatique parce que c'est surtout les
effets que ça va produire parce que sur
l'image de l'Europe les je suis les
décisions évidemment comme ça créer une
sorte de d'élan notamment en France
c'est de vote ne serait pas intervenus
évidemment parce que les intérêts qui en
face on parlait de la Chine on peut
parler de l'Indonésie on peut parler du
Brésil etc etc aurait sans doute à la
réussite à pilonner ces deux votes alors
il y a il y a un mot sur lequel je
voudrais qu'on revienne vous l'avez je
sais plus si c'est vous qui l'avez
utilisé c'est le mot impunité et je vous
propose deux éléments sonores tout de
suite le premier il nous vient de la
député européenne elle est fi Manon
Aubry elle avait exprimé ces soupçons
quelques jours après donc ce avoir
présenté cette résolution sur la
violation des droits humains au Qatar on
est le 24 novembre et sur son compte
Twitter elle publie ce message écoutez
on a réussi en début de semaine à enfin
faire voter le Parlement et acter le
fait qu'on fasse cette résolution cette
semaine manifestement il y a des groupes
qui n'en voulaient pas et qui ont voté
contre et qui sont venus pourrir les
négociations et à un point où je me
demande en fait si autour de la table
des négociations est-ce qu'on avait des
représentants des groupes politique où
est-ce qu'on n'avait pas tout simplement
l'ambassade du Qatar donc voilà soupçon
qui est très clairement exprimé on est
le 24 novembre donc il y a à peu près
trois semaines et puis alors quelques
jours auparavant là on est le 19
novembre on est sur notre antenne dans
l'émission ici l'Europe et on se
retrouve avec un euro député belge lui
aussi membre du groupe socialiste il
s'appelle Marc Tarabella il est
vice-président de la délégation pour les
relations avec la péninsule arabique
voilà ce qu'il disait dans l'émission
forcément nous aussi on réécoute ces
passages là avec un autre
œil et oreille il y a eu des morts
personne ne le dit mais la caricature
que fait monsieur toi seul aujourd'hui
et nuisible pour les droits de l'homme
globalement pourquoi parce que le Qatar
est le seul pays de la zone de la
péninsule arabique a fait de réels
efforts certains parfaits et le disent
eux-mêmes on n'est pas parfait et
d'ailleurs une des difficultés aussi
c'est la l'alimentation par exemple des
entreprises qui qui sont réticentes à
faire appliquer les changements et les
lois qui ont été votées ils doivent
nommer des contrôleurs ils doivent non
ils ont nommer les cours et des cours de
travail et donc ils le disent même
qu'ils sont pas parfaits voilà marque
tarbella qui a été qui a fait l'objet
d'une perquisition lui aussi dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche dernier dans
le cadre de cette enquête il n'a pas été
placé en détention provisoire voilà vous
comprenez bien pourquoi j'utilise ces
deux sonoresdel impunité pour vous dites
ça c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des députés
européens qui qui se sentent dans un
dans dans un système peut-être que le
Parlement profiter du système en quelque
sorte peut-être que certains élus se
disent ça notamment les élus qui
viennent de pays où la lutte contre la
corruption est moins poussée que que
chez nous je pense notamment aux pays
d'Europe centrale et d'Europe du Sud
voilà c'est des choses c'est des vous
voulez la corruption c'est c'est une
mentalité aussi
c'est c'est
avant tout une faillite enfin c'est une
faillite politique parce qu'on n'est pas
capable d'empêcher que ça se passe de
mettre des garde-fou réglementaires mais
c'est aussi une fight morale et quand un
pays comme le Qatar vient avec des
valises d'argent c'est parce que chez
lui ça marche comme ça
donc en fait tous ces pays là qu'on a
cité depuis tout à l'heure la Russie la
Chine le Qatar qui ont ces pratiques
c'est à dire qui pensent que en nous
donnant de l'argent ils peuvent obtenir
des décisions favorables de notre part
sur les sujets qui les concernent c'est
aussi ça traduit une culture qui est
peut-être la leur enfin en tout cas
c'est ce que montre tous les classements
internationaux mais c'est à nous de dire
que nous nous sommes pas comme ça que
nous ne voulons pas de ça parce que si
on verse là dedans c'est pas simplement
nous c'est pas simplement à nous qu'on
fait du mal c'est aussi aux populations
de ces pays-là qui comptent sur notre
exemplarité pour peut-être améliorer la
situation vis-à-vis de la corruption
dans chez eux Mélanie Vogel on a vu que
la vice-présidente donc avait été à
l'unanimité déchu de son de son poste
vous nous dites que vous posez des
questions sur une partie large du groupe
socialiste au sein de de ce Parlement
européen est-ce que on peut imaginer des
sanctions qui toucheraient un groupe
politique alors là encore une fois on
est au tout début de l'enquête donc moi
ce que je dis je suis pas du tout en
train de dire que tout le tous les
membres du groupe socialiste sont
corrompus je dis juste à l'exception de
des socialistes français ils ont tous
voté quelque chose qui du point de vue
des socialistes et des valeurs qui
défendent normalement n'a aucune espèce
de cohérence ça n'a aucun sens d'avoir
l'ensemble du groupe socialiste européen
qui vote contre le fait d'avoir une
résolution sur l'état des droits humains
au Qatar enfin je veux dire ça n'existe
pas donc je dis simplement que ce n'est
pas ça ne peut pas être voilà la paume
pourrie c'est tout un cas isolé il y a
forcément sinon ça ne peut pas marcher
ça arrive dans un d'ailleurs l'enquête
de la police belge elle est elle remonte
à plusieurs mois et visiblement c'est
des réseaux qui ont commencé à se mettre
en place il y a plusieurs années parce
qu'il faut du temps pour aussi voilà
avoir de multiples acteurs qui vont
acquérir la confiance ici et là voilà
pour que ça puisse marcher et entraîner
l'ensemble d'un groupe enfin voilà
donc d'un point de vue légal il y a pas
de sanction d'un groupe en revanche
en revanche elle était vice-présidente
donc elle ne l'est plus je suis pas
convaincu que ce soit la meilleure idée
du monde que y ait une nouvelle ou un
nouveau socialiste qui l'a remplace je
pense que peut-être pour que la
confiance revienne la personne qui la
remplace ce serait peut-être bien que ce
soit quelqu'un d'un autre groupe qui va
pour le coup avec un profil très fort
sur la lutte contre la corruption et
pour l'éthique en politique mettre en
oeuvre des mesures fortes au Parlement
européen parce que c'est pas qu'une
question de groupe politique c'est aussi
la légitimité de la démocratie
européenne et de l'institution du
Parlement européen dans son ensemble
qu'il faut protéger ça touche quand même
la plupart des groupes peut-être pas le
groupe vert mais je pense notamment au
groupe PPE qui pendant 10 ans a protéger
Victor urban bien sûr dont la corruption
n'est plus à prouver donc il y a eu des
des problèmes dans l'ensemble des
groupes européens peut-être Mathieu
vous quand vous aviez pardon quand vous
avez siéger au
parlementaire politique de ces questions
est-ce que vous avez été plusieurs fois
surprise par ces votes bizarroïdes c'est
consignes de vote étonnante il y a aussi
des histoires des députés des zéro
députés qui votent et puis qui se disent
qu'ils se sont trompés de boutons et qui
vont corriger le vote derrière il y en a
beaucoup alors sur sur les questions sur
le Qatar non mais on avait par exemple
au moment où on a fait la réforme du
registre de transparence des lobbys les
écologistes avaient fortement poussé à
cette époque là donc deux trois ans
l'inquiétude qu'on avait surtout c'était
l'Arabie Saoudite parce qu'on savait que
l'Arabie Saoudite via des entreprises
privées faisaient du lobbying indirect
il voulait pas dire que c'était eux donc
ils payaient des gens pour le faire à
leur place et nous on voulait que ce
soit publié
et que ce soit connu et aujourd'hui
c'est pas le cas
qu'on est des réticences de la droite
des conservateurs c'est pas très
surprenant mais on a toujours eu des
réticences et socialistes et c'est vrai
que
d'un point de vue des valeurs qu'on
défend c'est ça a toujours été surprend
les socialistes n'ont jamais été très
après avec la pression publique qui
suivait mais très favorable à renforcer
tout ce qui était tout ce qui pouvait
contraindre l'activité des députés
notamment publiés ces rendez-vous avec
les lobbystes ils nous ont toujours dit
que c'était leur liberté absolue de
rencontrer qui il voulait quand il s'est
stagi de voilà de publier plus sur les
intérêts financiers d'avoir plus de
contrôle en général ça a toujours été
compliqué délégation française mise à
part pas pas d'autres allemandes
néerlandaise je sais pas
dire mais c'est vrai qu'il y a tellement
de différences entre les parties
socialistes en Europe je pense notamment
par exemple socialiste qui a des
positions nationales qu'on pourrait
qualifier ou celle de rassemblement
national chez nous quoi tout à fait donc
alors vous ne l'avez dit on est dans
en tout cas présumé puisque l'enquête
démarre de corruption même s'il y a eu
un flagrant délit mais ça pose quand
même cette question des lobbies des
lobbys éthiques des lobbys économiques
on va y venir tout de suite grâce à
Audrey veettaz mais bonsoir Audrey juste
avant de vous entendre j'avais oublié je
voudrais qu'on écoute la réaction de la
présidente du Parlement européen
excusez-moi les amis en régie puisque
elle veut faire le ménage sur cette
question des lombies on l'écoute Roberta
metzella
on ne mettra pas la poussière sous le
tapis nous allons lancer une enquête
interne pour examiner tous les faits
liés au Parlement et voir comment nos
systèmes peuvent devenir encore plus
étanches il n'y aura pas de business à
jour nous lancerons un processus de
réforme pour voir qui a accès à nos
locaux comment ces organisations ONG et
personne sont financées quelles sont
leurs liens avec les pays tiers
nous demanderons plus de transparence
sur les rencontres avec les acteurs
étrangers et ceux qui leur sont liés
et donc Audrey déjà est-ce qu'ils sont
extrêmement nombreux à Bruxelles oui à
Bruxelles il y en a 1300013000
organisations enregistrées au registre
des lobbies créé en 2011 c'est le
deuxième plus grand registre au monde
derrière Washington il faut dire qu'un
lobby ça peut être beaucoup de choses ça
peut être une multinationale mais aussi
une ONG ou la représentation d'un pays
et c'est quelque chose qui est
couramment admis à Bruxelles ou à
Strasbourg ou les politiques estiment
qu'ils ne sont pas omniscients qu'ils
ont besoin d'avoir toutes les parties
prenantes avant de faire la loi
quels sont les règles justement qui
encadrent ces pratiques alors elles sont
très différentes selon les institutions
si c'est un lobby qui veut s'entretenir
avec une personne de la Commission
européenne l'organe exécutif il faut
absolument qu'il s'inscrivent sur le
registre dont je viens de parler le
lobby doigt indiqué son identité son
pays les moyens mis à sa disposition et
même les dossiers qu'il souhaite
influencer mais du côté du Parlement
européen il n'y a rien d'obligatoire un
député peut rencontrer sans problème un
lobby qui ne joue pas la carte de la
transparence même s'il y a quand même
des règles du jeu plus strictes pour les
députés qui sont chargés des dossiers
législatifs ça c'est des règles en
interne mais dans les faits c'est
compliqué à vérifier comme me l'a
expliqué l'ongs par Annecy
internationale
donc depuis juin 2019 seul un presque un
peu plus de 1 député sur deux ont publié
une rencontre réglée certains députés
ont peut-être pu seulement une ou deux
d'autres plus de 300 et malheureusement
parce que les règles sont un petit peu
compliquées c'est extrêmement difficile
pour nous de vérifier qui obéirait et
qui n'obéit pas aux règles alors est-ce
qu'il y a des contrôles en interne non
il y a aucun organe pour enquêter en
général ce sont les ONG les journalistes
où on l'a vu la justice qui met toujours
les manquements et en termes de
sanctions c'est une gigantesque cuisine
à gaz écoutez
le seul moyen que pour qu'il y ait
sanction c'est sur conseil d'un comité
consultatif qui sera qui est composé
lui-même de députés européens et qui se
rassemblent uniquement sur la demande de
la présidente du Parlement européen et
une fois qu'il sera simple et qu'ils
estiment qu'il y ait un moment il
conseille si oui ou non de sanctionner
mais la décision la seule décision de
sanctionner appartient à la présidence
où à l'époque au président et nous avons
remarqué que dans le la législature
précédente sur cinq ans il y a eu 24
manquements au code de conduite et 0
sanction donc visiblement à chaque fois
le président ou la présidente a opté de
protéger l'intestination institution
plutôt que de montrer l'exemple et en
fait de créer une sorte de culture
d'intégrité au sein de l'institution
même plusieurs voix s'élèvent donc je
vous en avez parlé pour créer une
autorité de contrôle indépendante un peu
comme notre haute autorité pour la vie
publique en France ça permettrait de
mieux contrôler les lobbys de mieux
contrôler aussi le système de
pantouflage dont vous avez parlé pour
l'instant rien d'encadre cette pratique
au niveau merci beaucoup Audrey à tout à
l'heure dans notre second
est-ce que cette place des lobbies c'est
aussi le symbole d'une Europe qui est
nourrie de libéralisme économique
finalement
non je veux dire ça parle pas de ça me
semble-t-il ça parle plutôt du fait que
depuis sa création la Communauté
économique européenne
comment dire
c'est un peu une conséquence on pourrait
dire comme ça c'est un peu une
conséquence disons de ce qu'on a fini
par appeler dans les années 90 le
déficit démocratique c'est-à-dire que
depuis le début depuis donc les années
1950 les autorités européennes
c'est-à-dire les états quand ils se
réunissaient ensemble la Commission
européenne les institutions européennes
et puis à partir de 79 le Parlement
européen il lui suffrage universel on
cherchait des interlocuteurs pour
pouvoir dire nous sommes en prise avec
la société européenne qui est donc il y
a eu comme ça une espèce de convergence
à la fois des acteurs et on retrouve ça
assez bien d'ailleurs dans la
littérature académique pour considérer
que les groupes d'intérêt et votre
journaliste l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est
une définition extrêmement large les ONG
les fédérations de branches les
syndicats etc ce structure en comment
dire en représentation voilà donc les
groupes d'intérêts alors je sais qu'en
français le terme le groupe d'intérêt
est pire encore le terme de lobby il y a
un petit côté les vampires qui sont dans
l'ombre mais en réalité
c'est l'idée que il faut des
interlocuteurs qui représentent la
société civile ou en tous les cas les
communautés sociales pour pouvoir ne pas
faire des lois ou prendre des décisions
en étant sinon
d'être dans leur tour d'ivoire ou d'être
hors-sol etc mais en effet
à un moment donné ce que tant les
chercheurs qu'un certain nombre
d'acteurs politiques ont dit certes mais
ça suffit pas à combler ce qu'on a pu
appeler les visites démocratique voilà
donc le fait qu'il y ait
des groupes de pression enfin je cite
mon collègue Olivier Costa qui est
vraiment le grand spécialiste français
sur le Parlement européen les activités
des groupes de pression sont déjà fort
réguler à l'échelle des institutions
européennes il a écrit ça dans un
conversation hier vous le disiez tout à
l'heure et c'est le cas donc on peut
faire plus évidemment il faut faire plus
mais la question de la corruption c'est
une question est-ce que les puissances
étrangère sont considérés que dans des
groupes de pression
catharyn est-ce que est-ce que donc ça
c'est une matière très importante de
faire plus le pantouflage on en a parlé
tout à l'heure ce qu'il faudrait
peut-être faire aussi puisqu'on parlait
de transparent aussi internationale ce
cette ONG avait en 2018
mis à jour le fait que environ je pense
que votre contrôle un tiers des députés
européens avaient une activité rémunérée
en parallèle de leur mandat et pour
beaucoup même s'il y avait y compris des
joueurs de poker professionnel
pour beaucoup c'est souvent soit des
avocats soit du Conseil bon et là il y a
clairement des choses qu'on peut réguler
c'est sûr alors on va effectivement
centrer sur la question de du lobbying
étatique donc il est il est il est c'est
quoi c'est une zone d'ombre en général
voilà c'est ça c'est que dans la
définition qu'on a aujourd'hui et alors
bon le fait qu'il y ait du lobbying
c'est tout à fait normal en soi à
Bruxelles il y a des institutions très
importantes qui prennent des décisions
majeures donc c'est logique que des
groupes d'intérêts essayent de les
influencer enfin je veux dire ça arrive
à Paris aussi donc ça c'est pas étonnant
le problème c'est quand le lobbying est
exercée de façon abusive et qu'il et
qu'il conduit au fait que des décisions
soient prises au nom d'intérêt privé
plutôt que public mais je reviens sur
les états parce que ça rejoint ce que
vous disiez finalement tout à l'heure
que sur une Europe qui se défend pas
suffisamment c'est vrai en fait on a bon
on a des rapports diplomatiques
non enfin c'est normal qu'on ait des
relations diplomatiques avec les autres
États et donc on ne les considère pas
comme étant des représentants d'intérêts
privés on les considère comme étant des
diplomates et on considère que c'est un
autre type de relation que des relations
avec des entreprises ou des ONG etc le
problème c'est que il y a certains dans
le monde qui pour différentes raisons
que ce soit la Russie que ce soit la
Chine que ce soit l'Arabie saoudite le
Qatar et j'en passe
ont des intérêts qui sont
contraire aux nôtres à la fois sur des
questions économiques et sociales mais
aussi et c'est là où je diffère un petit
peu ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
je pense qu'il y a certains il y a
certains pays dans le monde qui n'ont
pas intérêt à ce que l'Europe soit une
démocratie forte qui fonctionne bien et
qui donc ont intérêt à fragiliser nos
institutions démocratiques et donc ça
nécessite qu'on se protège contre les
influences pas seulement la Chine a
besoin qu'on fasse ça parce que c'est
panneaux solaires machin mais aussi des
puissances étrangères qui n'ont pas
intérêt à ce que la démocratie
fonctionne bien en Europe un mot
là-dessus chlory d'elle c'est peut-être
une plus de transi il y a de la
transparence aussi un contrôle pour le
lobby en général il faut l'instituer
aussi pour les relations avec des
représentants d'États qui viennent au
Parlement européen ça c'est un peu la
leçon à tirer évidente en tout cas une
transparence dire ça n'a jamais heurté
personne de faire la transparence sur
des rendez-vous qui refusé avec des
puissances étrangères et qui plus est
quand c'est puissant ne partagent pas du
tout notre modèle de civilisation je
pense que on est dans une mondialisation
multipolaire chaotique où vous avez de
nombreuses puissances qui revendiquent
un modèle de façon offensive et
défensive et que l'Europe doit faire la
même chose c'est-à-dire que l'Europe
doit faire corps pour défendre son
modèle de civilisation qui se
caractérise par une façon de vivre en
général par un ensemble de droits
d'institutions de mécanismes de
protection sociale et que depuis 20 ans
l'Union européenne a fait le contraire
de cela c'est-à-dire qu'on a été faible
face aux puissances de l'argent et on a
été faible face aux puissances
étrangères et cette affaire en dehors du
cas précis de corruption qu'elle
concerne nous rappelle à ça et mais
j'observe quand même sur une pour finir
sur une note un peu positive que depuis
le début de la guerre en Ukraine il y a
une vraie prise de conscience que il y a
eu ce rapport du Parlement européen sur
les ingérences étrangères qu'il y a eu
d'ailleurs je parlais des passeports
dorés tout à l'heure la commission qui a
dit qu'en fin disons après que c'était
est égal et qu'il fallait stopper
maintenant il y a cette affaire qui va
nous amener peut-être à créer une
autorité éthique au niveau européen donc
voilà les choses progressent et la prise
de conscience et là parce que ça ce
n'est pas seulement un problème
politique mais après moral un tout petit
mot Sylvain mais vraiment vraiment
rapide parce que j'aurais qu'on parle de
la visite d'Emmanuel Macron au Qatar
quand même dans ce contexte qui est
intéressant il nous reste 5 minutes donc
un mot rapide là-dessus pour dire que il
y a quand même une prise de conscience
c'est une action notamment vis-à-vis de
la Chine depuis 2019 la Chine est
identifiée par l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne comme un rival systémique par
exemple ça a des conséquences pratiques
sur dans le domaine législatif bon alors
donc on est dans ce contexte le Qatar
mis en cause même si j'ai effectivement
le lendemain au démarrage et Emmanuel
Macron qui va comme prévu Mathieu
soutenir les Bleus en demi-finale de la
Coupe du Monde oui moi confusion c'est
que ça ne fait pas l'unanimité le
Président c'est vrai avait pourtant
prévenu qu'il se rendrait au Qatar pour
soutenir les Bleus en cas où se qualifié
pour une demi-finale et pour une finale
donc on verra
les doigts pour pour mercredi soir mais
les polémiques ont émaillé
l'organisation et les conditions du
déroulement de cette coupe du monde
continue de scandaliser une partie de la
classe politique à gauche notamment d'où
viennent les critiques les plus
violentes par la voie de l'écologie
Jadot par exemple qui a demandé
solennellement à Emmanuel Macron de
renoncer à son voyage ou par celle de
l'insoumi Manuel Bompard qui a demandé
lui au président de aussi de renoncer
parce qu'il a c'était selon lui un tort
qu'il se rendait au Qatar et puis à
l'extrême droite on a eu le président du
RN Jordan Bardella qui lui refuse de
parler de fautes du chef de l'État mais
dit que titre personnel il n'y serait
pas allé s'il avait été concerné on en
est pas là Emmanuel Macron bah de faire
peu de Cats ces grands principes au fond
parce que la liste des grief elle est
longue quand même sur cette Coupe du
Monde et pose beaucoup de questions sur
les conditions de travail des ouvriers
qui ont construit les stades on te
rappelle que les ONG parlent de
plusieurs milliers de morts sur le
respect des droits humains ceux des
femmes des minorités je pense évidemment
à la communauté LGBT sur l'aberration
écologique de cette Coupe du monde en
plein désert avec les stats climatisés
sur les conditions d'attribution cette
Coupe du Monde qui font l'objet
rappelons-le quand même d'une enquête du
parquet national financier en France
voilà et puis depuis donc deux jours ça
joue à cette liste ce nouveau scandale
qui et sur un registre un petit peu
différent quand même parce que là on ne
parle pas de pratique qui se
pratiqueraient au Qatar mais d'une
ingérence du Qatar sur les intérêts
européens c'est mon avis change la donne
mais alors avec toute cette piste
pourquoi il va quand même officiellement
pour soutenir les Bleus dans ce qui sera
un moment important du sport français et
de l'amitié marocaine ça c'est ce qui a
expliqué l'Élysée hier soir on sait que
le président aime à se dépeindre comme
un fan de football dans Le Parisien la
semaine dernière il confiait échanger
régulièrement avec Didier Deschamps mais
derrière ça intéresse sportif il y a
évidemment quelques arrière-pensées
politiques ce qui manque pas de sel
quand même de la part d'un président qui
nous appelait à ne pas politiser le
sport ou sonner avant l'ouverture de la
compétition en fait tout le monde a un
chiffre à l'esprit à l'Elysée ou dans
l'exécutif ce sont les fameux 18 points
18 points qui avaient pris Jacques
Chirac en 1998 après la victoire des
Bleus de zinatine Zidane dans les
sondages alors en 2018 en 2018 il n'en
avait rien été et en cohabitation et
Lionel josman on en avait pas pris en
2018 il n'en a rien été l'optimisme des
Français avait bandit mais pas la cote
de popularité d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'époque il faut dire celui-ci avait été
accusé d'avoir confisqué votre fin
d'avoir voulu confisquer la victoire des
Bleus vous souvenez en faisant descendre
au pas de charge le bus des joueurs sur
les Champs-Élysées pour qu'il soit
attendre au palais présidentiel pour les
pour les JT de 20h et puis rappelons
qu'après cette victoire des Bleus en
2018 était arrivé une autre affaire
l'affaire Benalla sans doute voilà vous
savez
un peu plus tard voilà l'automne
mais le niveau gel ce scandale de
corruption bon il y a tous les arguments
qu'on connaissait avant mais ça ça
change encore la donne pour une raison
supplémentaire pour ne pas y aller vous
ne pouvez pas dire autre chose imagine
oui c'est pas parce que enfin je
pourrais dire autre chose si je pensais
à autre chose mais je passais un
argument additionnel c'est à dire que il
va il va s'y rendre malgré tout moi le
fait que les gens regardent de foot
c'est tout à fait normal il y a pas de
problème le fait que le Président de la
République
au Qatar alors que le Qatar vient d'être
accusé avec des éléments en promo de
mettre en danger notre démocratie et ben
ça envoie encore on est au tout début de
l'enquête donc ce qui peut en tant que
chef d'État faire comme si le Qatar
était nommément désigné par les
enquêteurs belges ce qui n'est pas le
cas donc bon il peut faire autre chose
que comme si de rien n'était hein il a
la possibilité de faire la tribune
officielle
il va y aller avec quel message il va
dire quoi rien allez les bleus ou il va
avoir un message politique sur tout ce
qui ne va pas au Qatar avec cette coupe
du monde et aussi sur ce qui vient de se
passer au Parlement européen ça c'est un
peu aussi la question il est pas obligé
de faire comme si de rien n'était ça
c'est un choix
sur sur la présence d'Emmanuel Macron au
Qatar dans ce contexte je dis encore une
fois est-ce qu'il peut faire autrement
en tant que chef d'État français c'est
plus facile évidemment quand on est dans
l'opposition de dire il faut boycotter
l'événement il faut surtout pas y aller
etc etc non mais c'est vrai que ça
présence en tant que chef d'État vient
cautionner vient cautionner vient
cautionner tout ça enfin c'est une
question délicate si vous voulez mais
dans la mesure où la France a une
responsabilité énorme sur le fait que
cette coupe soit organisée au Qatar
peut-être que ça aurait été un signal
d'autant plus important que le chef de
l'État français
refuse de s'y rendre même si notre
équipe étant demi-finale pour signaler
que une erreur avait été faite et une
forme de conséquences de cette erreur
notamment mentale en terme de droit
humain
d'arc-en-ciel voilà par exemple
et puis après ça va dépendre de ce qui
va dire effectivement c'est à dire bon
il faut bah là il faut qu'il soit malin
agile qui fasse du en même temps
c'est ça qu'on attend de lui puisque
c'est le roi du en même temps donc il
faut qu'il aille à la fois soutenir
l'équipe de foot National et en même
temps qu'ils disent ce qu'il a à dire
une fois qu'il sera sur place à la fois
au catary à la fois au monde et à la
fois au français et à la fois la au
Parlement européen aussi pour le
Parlement européen c'est bien souvent on
l'a évoqué la question de la confiance
des citoyens français et européens
envers cette institution merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat Chloé
je l'appelle le titre de votre livre
d'une guerre à l'autre qui est publié
aux Éditions de l'Aube et puis Sylvain
cas je rappelle que votre podcast
l'Europe des présidents est disponible
sur wave audio merci encore
merci
et toutes les plateformes j'ai rajouté
et toutes les plateformes comme ça comme
ça on est on peut vous écouter un peu
partout c'est une bonne nouvelle